اثار مقطع فيديو لسرقه طريفه وغريبه في ان
واحد باحدى المدن العراقيه سخريه رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل كبير فقد
اظهرت كاميرات مراقبه لحظه قيام شاب بسرقه
سمكه مسقوف اثناء عمليه شوائها على النار
في الشارع نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضجت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بمقاطع فيديو
توثقوا ظهور قط وفار يتجولان في وحده
عنايه مركزه بمستشفى مرجان بمحافظه بابل
وشباها عراقيون ساخروا بمحاكاه المسلسل
الكرتوني توم وجيري في مقاله مدير دائره
الصحه بالمحافظه ان المقطع قديم وان
السلطات الصحيه تعمل على الانتقال الى
ردهه جديده داخل المستشفى ذاته يتم التحكم
بها بشكل افضل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقاطع
فيديو للفنان المغربي سعد المجرد وهو يمثل
امام القضاء الفرنسي في قضيه اتهامه
بالاغتصاب والى جواره زوجته التي حضرت
لمساندته سعد المجرد ادلى باعترافات غير
مسبوقه بطاعته الكوكايين فقط في المناسبات
قبل ان يتوقف عن ذلك لكنه انكر تهمه
الاغتصاب المنسوبه اليه
تحول زفاف رجل صيني الى كابوسا بعد مفاجاه
غير متوقعه اذ اقتحم الحفل 12 امراه كانت
تربطهن علاقه عاطفيه مع العريس وظهرت
الحبيبات السابقات وهنا يحملن لافته حمراء
كبيره كتب عليها سندمرك اليوم واعترف تشين
بانه تصرف بشكل سيء مع بعضه صديقاته الامر
الذي ادى الى حدوث خلافات بينه وبين زوجته
وعائلتها
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء